um language program yes indeed I would
say it has been one of the main themes
of my research since like forever it's a
vast subject and fascinating fascinating
subject so I want to tell you a little
bit about it I want to start out with
this quote I wrote this book it was
published in 2007. language
correspondence for Loop groups now
correspondence here doesn't mean
correspondence in the sense of sending
letters to each other although like once
and I have done that a lot over the
years here correspondence means a kind
of a relation like one-to-one
correspondence or something like that so
in the preface I say the language
program has emerged in recent years as a
blueprint for a grand unified theory of
mathematics and I have to confess I said
it a little bit a tongue-in-cheek you
know because in mathematics mathematics
is not like quantum physics or you know
where one can talk about the grand
unified theory because you have certain
interactions with certain forces and you
want to find one underlying Theory
describing all of them mathematics is
just too vast to have one all
encompassing
Theory you know but if there were one
the language program would probably come
closest
so interesting enough this this phrase
Grand unified theory of mathematics has
kind of cut on and in fact if you look
in the Wikipedia article you will see it
quoted as well so now let's try to live
up to the expectation I have one
question first okay why is it called
langlands language yeah language is a
person is a person this this guy look he
is a very interesting man Canadian born
he is professor emeritus at the famous
Institute for advanced study in
Princeton New Jersey The Institute which
you know had as his professors people
like Albert Einstein in fact
langlands has Einstein's office and in
this picture he is at his office which
is formerly Albert Einstein's office a
very nice office at my dad you know I I
I have collaborated with him so
privilege I had a chance to to spend
some time in that office language
program is named after Robert langlands
because he was the one who came up with
this ideas or the first set of ideas
that we now call the language program in
the late 60s
now what happened is that this idea is
actually propagated to other areas of
mathematics and that was due to research
by other people not necessarily
England's himself and I think that's why
so many mathematicians are and Quantum
physicists these days as well
uh so excited about uh about this
project about this Theory the fact that
there are certain patterns which one can
observe in many different areas of
mathematics such as number Theory
harmonic analysis geometry and now even
quantum physics to to set it up I want
to say that to me mathematics is
something like a kind of like a giant
jigsaw puzzle suppose that you are
solving a jigsaw puzzle but you don't
know what the final picture is going to
look like it's kind of harder but more
interesting because then the picture
will gradually emerge but usually people
start you know Finding pieces that fit
together and so on and so next thing you
know you have several islands or
continents of sorts on the on the big
table you just throw the pieces on big
table and several people start working
on this that's kind of like different
areas of mathematics I also sometimes I
use another analogy I say the continents
of mathematics so what are they for
instance number Theory
that was a study of numbers and
equations
um like the ones which we'll talk about
in a moment there is also another field
called harmonic analysis which is like
trying to decompose a sound of a
symphony into the kind of Elementary
harmonics and to the nodes played by
different instruments and that idea has
found sort of a great following in
mathematics where you kind of generalize
it to a much more General situations
rather than sound uh there is also
geometry obviously we all study
euclidean geometry in school but in fact
this is just one small example there is
also no euclidean geometry there are all
kinds of geometries and higher
Dimensions there are different shapes
and manifolds that we call them and so
on so there are all these islands as you
know when you are working on a puzzle
the most exciting moment is when you can
connect those islands that you have
built and that's what the language
program does it connects different
branches and different Islands or
different continents of mathematics and
specifically he started out with some
difficult questions in number theory of
the kind that we'll talk about in a
moment
and he was able to connect these
questions to uh questions in harmonic
analysis that have to do with analysis
functions with
um kind of like things that we study in
calculus so kind of totally different
domain right and uh the beauty of it is
that the question original questions
seem to be interactable seem to be
extremely hard unsolvable almost but
when you translate them into this other
domain harmonic analysis they have much
nicer structure and there are tools of
harmonic analysis which enable us to
solve them so there is a practical
advantage of this type of you know
approach because problems that up up
until then could not be solved suddenly
you find a way to solve them and not
just one specific problem but a whole
host a whole class of problems of that
nature you see so that's why people got
so excited about it and then they got
even more excited when
um this idea is propagated to other
fields like geometry and then more
recently quantum physics so but
historically language came up with this
when he was a he was a young man in the
late 60s and in fact he formulated his
ideas for the first time in a letter
to another mathematician a sort of a a
maestro Meister of mathematics Andre V
who was a professor in Princeton at the
time I will read it for you he says
Professor Bay in response to your
invitation to come and talk I wrote the
enclosed letter after I wrote it I
realized there was hardly a statement in
it of which I was certain if you are
willing to read it as pure speculation I
would appreciate this if not I'm sure
you have a waste basket handy a kind of
a understatement of the century you know
so is he being humble or do you think he
was not confident I think he was being
humble I think he knew the importance of
it but he kind of wanted it it's a bit
of a show off I guess it's like nah it's
not that important you know we call that
a humble break now don't we I guess so
okay so that's how the English program
was born so in the set of those notes
and then soon enough you know he wrote a
paper and so on and a lot of people
found out about it and those letters you
know this is late 60s so it's before the
internet so people were making zero
scopies of the of this letter and
sending to their colleagues and friends
around the world and within 10 years
hundreds of people working in this area
so now after all this build up right now
finally I have to show you what it is
about
and uh usually you know like time's up
okay Saved by the Bell but
you can have all the time you want yes I
will I will explain I will explain it so
I would like to give an example of this
uh of of what appears in the language
program that type of connection between
uh problems in two different fields
number Theory and harmonic analysis
and the example I'm going to give is
interesting for various reasons one of
which is that actually it is precisely
the the key result that was proved by
Andrew Wiles and Richard Taylor to
provide the final step in the proof of
probably the greatest uh unsolved
problem in mathematics which had been
solved by those papers namely firma's
Last Theorem you look at the equation a
to the N plus b to the N equals c to the
N where n is an integer greater than two
and a B and C are relatively prime
non-zero integers now if n were two then
we know many examples of solutions of
this equation like 3 squared plus 4
squared is equal to 5 squared
believed that this equation for n
greater than 2 does not have any integer
Solutions so an example would be a cube
plus b Cube equals c Cube does not have
a solution ABC
in non-zero integers obviously if you
allow one of them to be zero you could
have a is equal to C and B is equal to
zero so it'd have to be non-zero to make
it interesting right so and so the
theory what did
you can't do it so if you're miles of
course Therma famously wrote about it on
the margin of uh theophanto's book about
the integer equations saying that he
found a beautiful proof of this ethereum
but the margin of the book is too small
to contain it but because he claimed
that uh Pierre Verma had a great French
mathematician in the 17th century for
three for about 350 years people were
searching for the proof even though you
know I guess after one or two hundred
years it became clear they probably
didn't have it either he was just being
provocative or he was mistaken we don't
know already got it already got it maybe
he got it who knows right but in any
case it the fact that he claimed that to
have found it I think was a great
accelerator of the host of the whole
field because people really wanted to
and produce his proof So eventually it
was actually proved by uh in a very
different in a very complicated way not
by
you know there isn't nobody was able to
find a kind of Elementary proof where
basically you take c b to the end to the
right hand side and then like write as a
product or something it doesn't work it
doesn't seem to work so instead uh
mathematicians were able to relate this
statement to another statement which is
much harder to to formulate and that
statement is called shimura tanyama
vacancy after three great mathematicians
so very andreway is the one to whom a
language letter was addressed he had an
important part in this project as well
and shimurtayama were this great
Japanese mathematicians so they had this
conjecture which has to do with
mathematologics which are called
elliptic curves and so now so you have
two different conjectures there is
fermas Last Theorem well we call it
thermosla's theorem because he claimed
to have proved it
um these guys did not claim to have
problems they were honest about it they
would put it out as an open question and
in mathematics we call open questions
conjectures those were two conjectures
firma's Last Theorem and shimurtanayama
very conjecture and so the decisive step
in the proof of this was made by my
colleague here at Berkeley Ken ribbett
who I believe has been interviewed by a
number file as well he showed that
conjecture implies sharma's last year so
then the search was on for proof of this
conjecture because people knew that as
soon as you proved this one you get the
big prize right
it's not one of those Millennium prices
for the simple reason that Millennium
prices were created after the stadium
was proved but if Millennium prices were
created before then Andrew Wells and
Richard Taylor would collect a million
dollars I'm sure it would be would have
been included on that list but it was a
big prize and it is a result which is
probably the most famous of all
mathematical theorems
um it stood uh for 300 more than 350
years you know so that's quite something
these days I would say human hypothesis
is the the big prize but it has it was
formulated by Riemann at the end of the
19th century so it's a much younger
problem compared to verma's Last Theorem
so can rivets accomplishment was
basically showing there was a bridge
between the two that's right and so the
race was on to do this one because you
got that one for free exactly because he
rivet established this already and that
was a big deal this was in the 80s so
then now what's the connection to the
language program the connection is that
this is this can be viewed this as a
special case of language now when we say
language program it we are referring to
the whole set of ideas but one of the
central ideas of the language program is
What's called the language
correspondence
so it is about correspondence that is to
say relation
like one-to-one correspondence between
objects of different kind
and simultaneous can be seen as an
example of that language correspondence
so let's talk about simultaneous
conjecture
I want to give an example of what this
statement of this conjecture says and to
formulate it I need to remind you
something which is called a cloak
arithmetic normally we do you know
addition multiplication of integers in
the usual way but uh for instance when
we talk about time we uh you know in
here in North America we identify 30 we
don't say 13 hours we say 1 pm
right and uh so they don't say 14 but we
say 2 p.m so in other words we identify
numbers which are related by 12 or a
multiple of 12. that's why it's called
clock arithmetic
uh normally we have 12 hours well in
Europe it would be 24 I suppose so but
still you do module 24 it's called
module 24 clock arithmetic but instead
of 24 uh we could take any other whole
number and uh especially it's
interesting is to consider the case when
that number is a prime number so here's
an example where you have a clock which
has seven hours right so you identify
minus seven zero seven fourteen you
identify one eight fifteen and so on
right and so on so this is more this is
a this can be done for any prime number
11 13 and so on so now suppose you have
an equation here's a prime example a
prime no pun intended example of an
equation that is relevant to the story
remember I was talking about elliptic
curves so elliptic curves are is kind of
a fancy name for equations of this type
this type of equations in two variables
X and Y for which one of the variables
has degree appears in degree two and the
other variable appears in degree three
like here on the left hand side you have
y squared as the highest power of Y on
the right hand side you have the cube of
X as the highest power of X so this
equation defines what's called an
elliptic curve now why why is it called
it to curve well if you look and this
probably I should I should say it kind
of slow down a little bit and say it
more precisely one of the main ideas
that emerged in you know in mathematics
in the last hundred years is that
in some sense equations are more
important than Solutions you know it's
kind of interesting because I think a
lot of our teachers will should learn
from that because the emphasis in our
schools I think is too much on solving
things and solving means the easiest way
to solve is to memorize the formula and
that's why so few people actually have
good experience in their math classes
but if you realize that professional
mathematicians actually care about
equations a lot more than Solutions then
this would help you to kind of refocus
completely and reorient the teaching and
learning process
now what do I mean by equations
equations matter more than Solutions
because once you write an equation like
this
you can talk about its Solutions but you
can talk about its Solutions in
different domains for instance you can
ask what other values of X and Y in
whole numbers so that the left hand side
is equal to the right hand side that
means you look for Solutions in integers
we say or whole numbers right but you
can also look at Solutions in real
numbers
you can also look for Solutions in
complex numbers
and in fact if you look at the solutions
of such an equation and complex numbers
you will find that the the set of all
solutions can be presented as a Taurus
as a kind of surface of a donut
and that's what it's an example of
what's called a Riemann surface and you
know I always say that it's a Homer
Simpson's favorite treatment surface
this Human Services the torai they're
called elliptic curves so that's where
the name comes from it comes from the
solutions of this equation over complex
numbers
but for this story we are going to be
interested in Solutions of this equation
uh
modulo a prime number
you see so in other words we're looking
for X and Y
which are integers it's whole numbers
such that left hand side is equal to the
right hand side but not on the nose but
in the clock arithmetic with respect to
a given prime number so for instance if
we're doing it for prime number five it
would mean that we only need the left
hand side to be equal to the right hand
side up to a multiple of five so for
instance if they're equal up to 20 or up
to 15 or negative 5 and so on we will
call it a solution in that numerical
system are you saying that we would find
the solutions take them out convert them
into modulo 5 and that's what we're
interested in or are we only allowed to
take the modulo 5 numbers to start with
as our contenders that's right so first
of all is contenders let's see if it's
modular five we should only consider
number zero one two three four both four
x and for y so you're really narrowing
your options so there's only 25 options
and then you can just calculate on a
piece of paper uh what happens when you
substitute you know x equals 0 y equals
zero x equals one and all equals zero
and so on and you go through all of
these 25 cases and in some cases
the left hand side may be equal to the
right hand side on the nose like for
instance if you say x equals zero y
equals zero you see that both sides are
equal to zero so that's a solution for
sure not only modulo five but in fact
for integer solution right or you could
take for instance a four on the left
hand side and then if you calculate you
get 4 squared which is 16 plus 4 that's
20. and 24 hour purposes right now is
the same as good as zero so in fact I
have listed here all the solutions out
of 25 options out of the 25
possibilities namely X and Y being
between zero and four we find actually
there are four pairs X and Y for which
the left hand side is equal to the right
hand side sometimes on the nose and
sometimes up to a multiple five so for
instance x equals zero y equals zero
both sides are equal to zero x equals
one y equals zero both sides equal to
zero so these are amnesty Solutions x
equals zero y equals four that's the one
which I mentioned where you have left
hand side is 20 and the right hand side
is zero but that that also qualifies as
a solution in our current framework 20
is the same as 0 according to a clock
arithmetic module 5 right
and finally we also have x equals one y
equals zero where we also get the left
hand side is 20 and the right hand side
is zero again it is a solution so we
have four Solutions module five so even
though we had limited contenders it also
was becoming easier because we we were
becoming a little bit looser as what
equals means that's right that's right
so but you see that it's really a kind
of a problem that uh uh uh Elementary
School student can can solve you know it
takes it takes time so here you would
have to check uh 25 options and see for
which of those options the left hand
side is equal to the right hand side up
to a multiple five if you go to the next
prime number which is seven you would
have 49 options which is seven times
seven you would have seven possibilities
for X seven possibilities or for y then
it's more difficult so it will take you
longer but you can do it on a calculator
or you can program it and you can have a
simple program which can do it for you
know relatively High prime numbers
fairly quickly so here I have compiled
the list on the left colon you have
prime numbers 2 3 5 7 11 13. that's a
clock these are how many hours we have
in our clock we live in a strange kind
of like Wonderland where we have not 12
but let's say seven hours or I would
prefer 13 so today they would be longer
right so and then how many solutions so
we just saw that for prime number five
there are four Solutions it turns out
that for prime numbers two and three
there are also four solutions for each
for prime number seven there are nine
solutions for prime number 11 or 10
Solutions thirteen nine Solutions and so
on remember we are talking about the
same equation but in accordance with
what I said earlier you can have just
one equation but it can have Solutions
in different domains and in different
numerical systems here we have one
equation which can be viewed as an
equation with respect to the clock
arithmetic module or any prime number so
there are infinitely many possibilities
of what we could mean in this context by
a solution so if you say solve this
equation that's not a correctly uh
phrased question because then you can
ask back in which domain and so in fact
there are infinitely many possibilities
here
and they correspond to the choices of
prime numbers but for each of those
primes there is a well-defined number
the number of solutions and you can see
that it kind of grows so the prime
numbers grow and the number of solutions
grows so in fact it turns out I dropped
again like a 13 it dropped it dropped a
little bit but if you if it's possible
to compile a much longer list and you
will see that it kind of grows it's
almost equal to P itself but with some
small defect so that's why it's actually
useful to consider not the actual
numbers of solutions but the the kind of
a defect the difference between the
prime number itself p and the number of
solutions that you have module p so then
you see for instance if Prime is 5 we
found that there are four Solutions so
this number is equal to one because five
minus four is one likewise for seven you
have nine Solutions so suddenly it's a
little bit larger than the prime itself
so that defect is actually going to be a
negative number so this defects could be
both positive and negative and but
they're going to be fairly close to zero
they're not going to grow as fast as P
whereas this numbers grow as fast as P
so it's kind of a useful in
normalization if you will relabeling of
things
so now the question is what are these
numbers and from what we have said it
they look completely random and this
sequence looks completely chaotic there
is no if you well this is too short a
sample to actually make any conclusions
but obviously we can write a short
computer program so I could put them on
the screen because you could put them on
the screen uh the first 100 or whatever
right
oh but wait if you do it directly right
so if you do it directly you see that
it's a hard problem because each time
you have to set up a new problem because
for instance you go from five to seven
the results about prime number five have
no bearing on the results for prime
number seven unless you have found some
solution which is for which the left
hand side and right hand side are
coincide on the nose and not up to
multiple of a prime so then of course
such solutions would be valid for every
Prime but there are very few of those
so in fact oh yes because every equation
will have a different fingerprint like
here that's right because when we talk
about Solutions module five we saw that
there was uh there were there were four
Solutions only two of them were
Solutions where the left hand side is
actually literally equal to the right
hand side and for two other Solutions
the the two sides differed by 20 which
was a multiple of five but but 20 has
not means nothing for modulus seven it's
not equal to zero module seven obviously
if you have something divisible by five
it's not going to be divisible by seven
in principle because they're both prime
numbers right so for seven you have to
redo the whole calculation from scratch
then just as when you kind of like
you're tired and you're sweaty from that
you say okay now do it for prime number
11. so again you have to do it from
scratch right so you have instantly many
computational problems which have which
are priority looks like have nothing in
common and the numbers that you get look
completely random
so what if we could but what if we could
find another way to solve it what if I
told you that there is actually
a totally different approach to this
problem where all of these numbers
could be written sort of in one stroke
that's what the name conjecture says and
that's what the language program in
general the language correspondence in
general says it enables you to express
the solution of this seemingly
intractable problem in number Theory by
tools of harmonic analysis I realized
that the two columns are very very
linked to one another but are you
talking about trying to spit out column
two or column three column three so
column three is somehow is a little
better because
it's kind of uh you have things which
are kind of close average to zeros at
speak as opposed to growing as as a
prime number grows so column three
column three is where the where the meat
is the question is to express to find a
way to express all of these numbers for
all primes all at once by some Magic by
some miracle
so now I want to describe this
alternative solution which pops out
completely out of the blue so there is
no nothing in the original problem that
could suggest that there is a way to
solve it in this way so this is a kind
of insight this is something which
to me I still think we don't really
understand why we can prove it now but I
still consider it as a sort of a miracle
you know as a kind of black magic
honestly okay so here's how it works the
claim is that you can write a certain
infinite series and I will explain what
I mean by this in this variable queue Q
is like X but you know we already have X
in the equation so we just need a
different letter and so traditionally
mathematicians use letter q but it's
just a notation if you can use X or what
a z or whatever you like so there is
this thing which is called infinite
series which is written as this process
infinite product and I will explain what
it means which has the following
property that if you open it has a very
regular uh Behavior I'll explain what I
mean by that and then you can start
opening the brackets using the
traditional rules of how you multiply
you know various expressions of this of
this sort when you start opening the
brackets you're going to get an
expression which involves various powers
of Q and there will be some coefficients
appearing in front which will be a whole
number so positive or negative and I
claim that if you look at the power for
example the P the fifth power the
coefficient will be equal to exactly
that number in the third column
associate to five if you look at the
coefficient in seventh power you will
get number negative two which was the
number that we had in the third column
Associated to seven and if you look at
the eleventh power you get coefficient
one which is exactly what you get from
the counting problem right and if you
look at number 13
let's hope that this is correct
yes it is four
and so on so this one line of code if
you will if we take the coefficient of Q
to the power p p is a prime so like Q to
the five Q to the seven Q to the 11 Q to
the 13. if you take the coefficient in
front because each of these Powers gets
multiplied by something and call it B of
P then a of P which I recall is the
number which appears in the third column
earlier it will be equal to B of P for
all prime numbers
so as you see it's like forever forever
and there are instantly many primes as
we know right yeah so it is a solution
not to one not to five not a billion
problems it's a solution to infinitely
many problems in one line
it's a kind of a one-liner it's like if
it were if it were a stand-up comedy act
you know so it could be like that would
be like the the one liner of all one
liners which would contain all the jokes
that could that was ever told and that
will ever be told forever and ever as
the prime numbers get really really big
as prime numbers do to those
coefficients to those numbers in column
three stay around the vicinity of you
know one and three and or do they start
getting they grow they grow they will
grow but they will grow as a square root
of P
not as B so it's a kind of the growth is
much slower but they do get bigger they
do get bigger yes and and they can be
both positive and negative so they kind
of they are average they're more or less
average out to zero but occasionally
they can become large positive numbers
large negative numbers but always within
the square root of P
where p is the prime that we're talking
about right okay so colossal compression
of information
it's like you know fine it's like we're
really literally finding order in what
appeared to be a completely random
sequence of numbers a completely chaotic
sequence of numbers and so another way I
like to say is like it's like one line
of code gives us a simple rule which
kind of generates the DNA of the
accounting problem it feels magical to
me except I don't know where you got
that original algorithm from that's
right yeah that's right so now I want to
explain uh what I mean by by this by the
series first of all so to explain to as
a warm-up let me talk about this concept
which we call in mathematics uh
generating function
so if you have a sequence of numbers so
this would be number n natural numbers
one two three four five six and so on
suppose that you have a certain number
assigned to each the F of n so the
simplest sequence could be just one one
let's say one to all of them that's the
first example so then mathem I just have
this trick where they say I don't want
to look at this at this table instead I
convert it into what's called a
generating function or generating series
and so what this is is I will take F of
one and multiply by Q Plus F of 2
multiplied by Q squared F of 3
multiplied by Q Cube and so on or you
know we like this notation Sigma for the
summation sign and we'll say that we
just go from one to infinity and we put
F of n times Q to the N so what will
this generating function be in our first
example where we assign to every natural
number just number one it will look like
this a cube
plus Q squared plus Q Cube plus Q to the
force and so on right so you see well
there's not much of an improvement in
some sense because here you look
vertical kind of you go down vertically
here you go horizontally to the right
but you can play with this we can
rewrite this generating function in the
following way as Q times another
generating function which now starts
with one one plus Q Plus Q squared and
so on clearly if you open the brackets
this term will give you Q this term will
give you Q squared this term will give
you Q Cube and so on each number in the
sum is equal to Q times the previous
number and we know that if absolute
value of Q is less than one this series
actually converges to 1 divided by y 1
minus Q so that means that if
in this original series Q was just a
bookkeeping device it was just a
variable kind of indeterminate we don't
want to initially assign any value to it
but then we notice that in fact this
expression doesn't think some makes
sense if instead of Q we substitute an
actual number let's say a real number
from negative one to one or it could be
a complex number with absolute value
less than one then the series actually
converges converges for real not like
one plus two plus three plus four
where it actually diverges but then
there are ways to extract sort of
meaningful value here it actually it
actually converges according to all the
rules and so to this function 1 divided
by 1 minus Q so that this expression
becomes Q divided by 1 minus Q so you
see instead of this infinite table we
end up with this very cute looking
function so it contains information
about those numbers F of n in the
following sense that if you expand it in
powers of q that is to say reverse this
process and go from 1 divided by y minus
Q to this infinite series then you get
this series and from this you can read
off all the coefficients F of n which in
this case that trivial kind of the O
equal to one so that's the first example
let me give you one more example suppose
that you assign numbers not just once
but one two three four five six and so
on so then you're going to have a Q Plus
2 Q squared plus 3 Q Cube plus four Q to
the fourth so it's a little bit more
interesting now and so you say okay is
it possible to also convert it into
something like this and the answer is
yes in fact you can because you can also
rewrite it as Q times 1 plus 2q plus 3 Q
squared and so on I claim that in fact
this green Series in Brackets is the
derivative
by respect to Q of this series because
when you take and when we take
derivatives we are just doing it term by
term so one is a constant it's
derivative is zero so it will give
nothing Q will give you one the
derivative of Q is one with respect to Q
right this is dgq okay so Q will give
you one Q squared will give you 2q Q
Cube the next term will give you three Q
squared and you see that it's exactly
the pattern that you get each
coefficient is going to be an integer
one two three four because when you take
the derivative of Q to the N you get n
times Q to the N minus 1. now what it
suggests is that this sums up to the
derivative of this and for those who
remember their calculus course they will
immediately see that it is one divided
by 1 minus Q squared so you see the
result here so the result in a previous
example when all the numbers were equal
to one now we'll be so in that case it
was Q divided by one minus q but now
it's going to be Q divided by 1 minus Q
squared
so again you have a very compact
expression which contains information
about those numbers which in this case
if you if you reverse the process and
you expand this back into a generating
function you will see one two three four
and so on popping up skefficients in
front of the corresponding powers of Q
so that these are two basic examples of
the generating function and now the
function that we have here which appears
in the in the solution of the counting
problem is kind of like that except it
is written well you see here we in our
basic examples we were able to write
things in terms of kind of some simple
factors where we used actually geometric
progression so in fact here it was
essential that absolute value of Q was
less than one in some sense this is very
similar because except now we have only
positive powers of things like 1 minus Q
or 1 minus Q to the 11. but the meaning
of this expression uh is very similar to
what we have just discussed it is
something that would be converted into
into a series of the form F of 1 times Q
Plus F of 2 times Q squared plus F of 3
times Q Cube and so on by simply opening
the brackets so for instance in this
example F of 1 is is equal to one F of 2
is equal to negative two F of 3 is
negative 1 and so on now you may ask how
do I go from this line to this line
simply by opening brackets so you see
first of all there is some regularity in
this what is the what is the regularity
so there is a coefficient Q which is
kind of familiar to us now because in
our basic examples we also had a q as a
factor next it comes 1 minus U squared
we know how to open brackets 1 minus Q
squared is simply 1 minus two Q Plus Q
squared right so then we replace this
expression by 1 minus two Q Plus Q
squared likewise 1 minus Q
to the 11 squared is 1 minus 2 Q to the
11 plus Q to the power 22. so we replace
that square Pi by by this expression
then again comes something similar minus
Q squared so you see the regularity is
twofold so so to write down this
generating function uh first factor is Q
after that I write factors 1 minus Q
squared and I leave some space then I
write 1 minus Q squared squared and I
leave some space then I write 1 minus q
q squared do you get the idea yeah and
then in this basis I write something
similar I write 1 minus Q to the 11.
squared then here I write 1 minus Q to
the 22. 22 being of course twice 11
squared then I write 1 minus Q to the 33
always squared and there are two
sequences one is where you have one
minus q1 is Q squared when Q Cube and so
on so clearly the next one is one minus
Q so Square Cube fourth squared and
after that the red one is going to be 1
minus Q to the 44. squared and so on
right so that's clear now when you open
the brackets you may be wondering
whether it is legitimate because there
are infinitely many terms but because
the powers of Q are increasing as we
throw in more and more factors you you
see you can see clearly that when you
open the brackets the only finitely
manufacturers will affect the specific
power of Q for instance if you're
interested in Q squared it will come
from here it will come from here but
this is already Q to the 11 it's not
going to to contribute to Q squared
likewise if you want you know Q to the
power fourth or fifth this Q This terms
will not affect it so only finite in
many factors of this infinite product
will contribute to a specific power of
Cube that's why it is well defined so
the only thing that you need to do here
is just open the brackets and here I
give the expression for the first few
terms up to Q to the 13 and so the
statement of the name of a conjecture in
this particular case is that if you
focus not on all coefficients not on all
powers of Q the way we discussed in our
basic example but only the prime Powers
so you look just at the coefficients in
front of Q squared
Q Cube Q to the fifth Q to the seventh Q
to the eleven Q to the 13 and so on
where what do I what do they all of them
have in common they are all Q to the
power P where p is a prime number then
each of these monomials each of these
Powers will come with the coefficient so
the equation I call this B of two I will
call this B of three bo5 bo7 B of 11 B
of 13. and the statement is that this
for every p and p being a prime number B
of p is equal to a of P which gives the
solution of the counting problem for
that prime number namely I recall that
we are talking about the third colon so
a of p is not exactly the number of
solutions but it is p minus the number
of solutions that difference mod P
so all of these numbers which well if
you know this guys you know obviously
numbers of solutions because simply take
P minus that number right to get to get
the number of solutions so all of these
numbers can be found in one in one
stroke so to speak from the coefficients
of this one generating function
now what what what is the meaning of
this function where does it come from
right so and it turns out that this is
an example of what is called a modular
form
so in fact
this example illustrates the general
principle that we can link elliptic
curves
remember the this equation cubic
equation that we talked about
corresponds to the mathematical object
we call an elliptic curve
and so this elliptic curve like more
precisely counting problem counting
points
on an elliptic curve modulo prime
numbers can be linked
can be linked
to a modular form
in this way that the coefficients of the
modular form
give us more or less number of solutions
module prime number up to some simple
replacement and that statement is the
statement of the name of a conjecture
which is a special case of the language
correspondence
and that is a statement which gives us
the proof of verma's Last Theorem okay
nice speaking about elliptic curves I
want to mention these two books so this
this one called elliptic Tails curves
counting and number Theory so which
talks about a lot of the things that we
discussed today what this elliptic
curves look like and their Solutions in
different numerical systems and so on so
it's a really nice nice book explained
in Fairly you know understandable way
okay and I think will be interesting to
both mathematicians non-mathematicians
alike we'll link to it we'll link to it
we'll have a link in there and then the
uh
the other book is about cryptography
using elliptic curves so the elliptic
curves have recently found a real world
applications to cryptography and also I
want to mention in this regard that my
very first video
for number file was about an algorithm
actually it was not an encryption
algorithm but it was an algorithm for
generating student random numbers
that this algorithm was proposed by the
National Institute for standards and
technology in the United States and then
when Snowden revealed you know various
documents of NSA then people found out
that actually that algorithm was had a
back door installed by NSA and this was
important because those pseudo-random
numbers were used to generate passwords
and things like that various various
numbers which were used in other
algorithms so whoever had a back door to
that algorithm it had like a master key
to open all doors you know that's
actually the that Infamous publication
by the National Institute for standards
and Technology nist recommendation for
random number generation and then uh
then describes this Infamous dual
elliptic curve random bit generator dual
ecd-rbg here's the elliptic curve that
they used so in fact you can go back to
my old video and then I talk about in
more detail but you see this is an
equation very much like the one we have
discussed you have a second order
polynomial in y on the left and the
third order polynomial of degree three
cubic polynomial in X on the right hand
side and here is the prime number here's
how many hours the US government has in
on their clock
see how many digits there are so anyway
sometimes people ask you know this is
all very interesting but it looks very
abstract what are the real world
applications
and So my answer to that is oh oh there
are applications you can be sure of that
or if there aren't yet applications for
example of the type of questions we
discussed regard regarding simultaneous
conjunction and so on there will be
applications mathematics always finds
real world applications the question is
whether we will be wise enough not to
use it for evil purposes you know which
unfortunately has been the case with
some of the applications of mathematics
and science in general and let's now go
back and discuss modular forms so I
explained that this infinite product
represents What's called the modular
form and this is an object of harmonic
analysis so it's a totally different
continent of mathematics from number
Theory where our accounting problem
originated so what are these modular
forms it turns out that as I explained
in my sort of basic example of
generating series sometimes something
which appears as just a formal sum of
various powers of Q some coefficients
like this one can be converted in in
something which looks much nicer it's
kind of a more compact expression namely
one divided one by one minus Q so we
have to be mindful of the fact that this
equality holds only provided the Q the
absolute value of Q is less than one
that's when the series converges right
and then it converges to this expression
with modular forms the situation is very
similar
uh here we also have an expression of
this of this kind the coefficient of the
first part of Q is always going to be
one it's kind of a normalization for
this modular form then there will be F
of 2 Q squared F of 3 Q Cube plus Etc
right and it turns out that this
Expressions will also converge when Q
absolute value of Q is less than one but
in this case it is important to take not
just real numbers but complex numbers
now as you know complex numbers can be
represented by points on a plane where
the x-coordinate is the real part and
the y coordinate is the imaginary part
of the number so if you're interested in
numbers whose absolute value in the
sense of complex numbers less than one
they correspond to a disk of radius one
you've got to be inside that so these
numbers all have to be can be viewed as
points inside the disk so now we get
some geometry out of this so what starts
out as a as an infinite expression as a
kind of a summation of uh various powers
of Q with some coefficients even though
initially we write it as a product maybe
but you know eventually we can open the
brackets and find out all the
coefficients and so on but now we also
realize that actually this infinite
expression has a well-defined value for
any point inside the disk and every time
something like this happens you ask
whether this function that you get
because what we get is really a function
it's a rule which assigns to every Point
inside the unit disk on the complex
plane some context number whether this
function has any symmetries
and the the modular forms are defined
precisely by their symmetry properties
now before I explain what the Symmetry
property is I want to
discuss kind of a a baby version of this
kind of a simplified version of this
which has to do with trigonometric
functions
so in the case of trigonometric
functions the trigonometric function we
consider as functions on the real line
so you have for example sine of x
important property of trigonometric
function is that it is periodic so if
you add 2 pi to the argument you will
get the same thing right but in fact
then it means that if you add 4 Pi you
will also get the same thing if you add
6 Pi you get the same thing and so on so
in fact there is a whole bunch of
symmetries of this function which are
labeled by integers so you could add 2
pi times natural number and the
resulting function will be equal to the
original for any natural number or
natural number or actually any integer
so that's what I mean by symmetry that
you modify the argument in some precise
way but as a result the function does
not change so in this case the
symmetries are labeled by integers and
in fact symmetries form what's called a
group
so we can talk about the group of
symmetries and in this case the group of
symmetries
is a group of integers with respect to
addition the word group here means that
symmetries are not disjoint that we can
always take the sum or the difference of
any two symmetries and we will get a new
one and this addition amount and
subtraction is just the usual addition
and subtraction of natural numbers or
integers and the mathematics is love to
call it Z which is sort of like a double
line that's an addition we typically use
for the group of integers uh the the
cosine function has the same symmetries
the cosine function has the same
property that if you shift the argument
by any multiple of 2 pi you get back
there is no function and this is a
prototype a blueprint for studying uh
symmetries of various functions so now
let's go back to the context of modular
forms uh the difference now is that a
modular form is defined not on the real
line but rather it is defined on the
unit disk on a complex plane however it
turns out that it also enjoys this kind
of symmetry property the corresponding
group of symmetries is much more
sophisticated it is what is called sl2z
instead of explaining what it is I will
approach it in a more geometric way so
here we can encode the Symmetry property
of the trigonometric functions by
marking these points 2 pi n here the
point zero then this will be minus 2 pi
then there will be minus 4 pi and so on
and then here will be 2 pi and here will
be 4 pi and so on so uh the symmetries
correspond to shift lifting the real
line either to the right or to the left
by an integral multiple of 2 pi right
and we can try to represent uh the
action of this group or more precisely
it could be some subgroup it's called
the concurrent subgroup of this group
but it's a detail so let's ignore this
for now instead of trying to describe
how it acts I want to produce a picture
which is analogous to this picture where
the Symmetry the action of the
symmetries of the real line which with
respect to which the telemetric
functions remain unchanged is
represented only now on the unit disk
and for this I will consult a very
interesting book that I came across
recently
actually actually the purpose of this
book which came out you know nine years
ago was to give a kind of an exposition
of the language program to know for non
mathematicians so if a lot of pretty
much everything that I discussed today
is discussed in more detail in this book
so if you're interested in this in the
subject and that's what's one of the
sources you know also various talks that
I have given like the the slides that we
have seen which are available on YouTube
and so which probably you can link also
but I want to show you this uh this
picture now because it's hard for me to
draw it but I will show you in
so see this it talks about the terminal
as theorem and the connection to the
chimurtan Yama and here is the equation
that we discussed today and the
co-charismatic and generating functions
and all that and so there's a picture I
wanted to show you so this is the this
is the unit disk on the complex plane
and this sort of triangles are the
analogs of the intervals that you see on
the real line under the action of
symmetries of the trigonometric
functions this kind of a curved kind of
hyperbolic triangles are the analogues
of the what matters is called
fundamental domains for the Symmetry
group of modular forms or in in one of
the possible examples it could be a
picture a little bit different from that
but very similar to that so it's kind of
triangles but core of triangles the
triangles with respect to the hyperbolic
geometry non-euclidean geometry which
one can set up on the unit disk
so that's the story of modular forms
okay how are we going are we getting
there yeah we're almost there all right
and so now we have at least some sense
of what uh elliptic curves are what the
counting problem for elliptic curves is
and uh that's on one side of the
language correspondence or in this
particular case uh we're talking about
what's called the schmurt I am away
conjecture
and on the other side we have modular
forms and now we have a sense of what
what those are to put it simply the
small time away conjecture is about the
existence of a one-to-one correspondence
between
elliptic curves on one side and modular
forms on the other side
and this correspondence satisfies this
special property that the solution to
the counting problem for for a given
elliptic curve
can be read off of the coefficients of
the modular forms module form when you
write it as a generating function in the
variable queue when I say to you then
what is the language program it is the
toolkit and the methods and the
conjectures and the algorithms to join
these two parts of mathematics that's
right that probably didn't seem like
they were joined at all it's fine that's
right it's finding the hidden tunnels
this thread or Bridges or Building
Bridges you know so but you're right a
kind of hidden tunnel is maybe a better
way to put it because I think that even
though we could now prove a lot of
examples of this type of Correspondence
I still think it is mysterious I still
think we don't understand the underlying
reasons so in other words there is
something beneath the surface something
hidden there's some hidden we still
don't understand mathematicians today
don't understand which I think maybe in
100 years 200 years we will have a much
clearer understanding and people would
you know do a number of our video 100
years from now and they say you know 100
years ago people didn't understand what
was the reason for this correspondence
but actually it's so simple it is so
obvious you know so in high school yes
but now we don't see it yet but it's
important so it's important to emphasize
that there is this there are
disconnections
and that there probably is a good
explanation for this but it's important
to how do we how can we come across
those explanations we can come across by
studying them more deeply in more detail
and considering the same kind of
patterns
uh in other contexts as well you see so
in fact
the time away conjecture which we which
I have used to illustrate the general
ideas of the language program I was
known before the language language came
up with his idea so he knew that this
kind of an example so in fact the
language program talks about much more
General things than what we have
discussed so far and I wanted to just
indicate what they are so so far the
correspondence that we have seen is
between elliptic curves on one side
modular forms and the correspondence is
such that it matches certain numbers
attached to objects of both kinds on
this side you have this counting problem
and you get these numbers AP which is
basically number of solutions mod P more
precisely P minus a number of solutions
whereas on this side these are the
coefficients of the module form
confusion in front of Q to the power P
so that's the Prototype that's a
blueprint of how language program
language correspondence is formulated in
in general in general in the general
context
so what will be the objects in general
so the idea is that actually what
appears on this side in general is not
going to be necessarily a curve elliptic
curve or it's not necessarily going to
be some equation what is relevant to the
side is something that has to do with a
great French mathematician if that is
golua so he was this French genius who
died in a duel at the age of 20 but just
before he died he made these profound
contributions to mathematics he came up
with what we call today the gala group
group is a group of symmetries which you
see we have already encountered
symmetries on the side of modular forms
when we talked about symmetries of
modular forms being similar to the
symmetries of trigonometric functions
and so on but actually symmetries also
naturally appear on this side we can
call this side number theory side and
this side harmonic analysis side right
so symmetries are actually essential on
both sides and on the side of what we
see here as elliptic curves or on the
side of number theory in general what we
get is what's called representations of
the gala groups now it will probably
take us another bunch of videos to
um to explain what this means but I
discussed this I discussed this here so
this representation of Gala groups in
chapter 8 of love and math so that these
are the more General things which in the
case of simultaneama reduced to
elliptic curves can be connected to
ellipticals so it gives a much more a
kind of simplified way of describing
these objects in general we may not have
a specific equation which is behind this
object yet they can be defined
rigorously in number Theory so these are
the objects on the left hand side so to
speak of the language correspondence the
number theory side and the objects on
the other side on the right hand side
are called automorphic functions or
automorphic forms these are the
generalizations of the modular forums
and again the idea is that there is a
one-to-one respondents between the two
or sometimes could be mainly to one
because sometimes it can be depending on
how you phrase it sometimes it gets it
gets kind of more murky but in the
clearest examples that have been
understood so far one actually gets
one-to-one correspondence
getting one-to-one correspondence
between objects of two kinds is not so
interesting ultimately because you know
if you have both two countable sets so
you get a one-to-one correspondence
between two countable sets so what
but what really makes language
correspondence interesting and exciting
and what makes you know allows one to
use it as in applications is the fact
that under this correspondence certain
certain information from number Theory
which has to do with Galway groups gets
translated to analytic information that
has to do with Automotive functions
in the case of the that we have
discussed
I have explained what that information
is
on the side of elliptic curves these are
the numbers of solutions of the cubic
equation underlying this elliptic curve
and on the
harmonic analysis side these are the
coefficients of the module form in
general this data can also be expressed
more complex but they can be stated you
know precisely what they are and the
beauty and the power of the Linux
correspondence is that under this
correspondence those numbers match just
like they match in the keys that we have
discussed if any link is found between
any two continents of mathematics that
doesn't automatically mean it's language
is more specifically links between the
Galway groups and the automorphic
functions
right so you know I want to say
I want to say something that
um links between different continents
are it's a quite common occurrence in
mathematics and it's something very
which is prized precisely because it
indicates that there are some things
which you don't see yet which are
beneath the surface and if you look in
the history of mathematics that a lot of
the great discoveries were made when
mathematics somehow stumbled upon this
kind of links without understanding what
they are but eventually were able to
find an explanation and that was always
fueled progress in mathematics and so
this is an idea which I like to call
unification so there's a certain sense
of unity in mathematics that even you
know subjects which appear to be far
apart in fact are not so far apart
and so you know one of the simplest
examples just to illustrate what I mean
is the following if we just talk about
numbers natural numbers then of course
uh we know the uh kind of the simplest
way to introduce numbers by counting so
you have one pencil two pencil three
pencils but that's not the only way
let me show you another way
and for that I'm going to use a probe
you know my dentist always complains
that I don't I don't floss enough
but you see
so my dance will be proud of me if if
you watches this video what you can do
is you can also wrap the flaws this
thread on the finger you do it once you
do it twice it is three times four times
and so on you see so that's another way
to introduce numbers and the advantage
of this is that whereas all these
pencils are different so in fact when
you explain to Children numbers they say
but how can you all consider them as
objects of the same kind they have
different colors but here it's clearly
something of the same kind just kind of
what we call winding number how many
times the you know the floss has wound
up on my finger and the second Advantage
is that I can do it clockwise or
counterclockwise and this way I can
represent both uh positive and negative
numbers whereas I don't know what is a
negative one pencil but I know what is a
negative one a number in this
realization I just go clockwise instead
of counterclockwise you see so this is
for me is basic illustration of unity of
mathematics that the same concept the
same idea namely in this case a very
basic idea of natural numbers arises
from two areas of mathematics this we
could School counting is number Theory
and this is what's called topology the
study of these windings and so on is you
know one of the illustrations of of the
field of mathematics or continent of
mathematics called topology and so
ultimately I think
mathematicians always find it extremely
exciting and and fruitful to find those
connections to find different ways and
you can think of this as different ways
of looking at the same thing so it's
like you know uh if I have this I can
look it from above I can look from the
side and so on so ultimately the myth
ranks is a kind of a mysterious Beast
which we can observe from different
sides and to me that those connections
that we find
like the ones we have talked about today
are in indications that we are looking
from different angles at the same object
and you tell me like the langlands
programs finding all these exciting
connections between representation of
galawar groups and automorphic functions
I don't know what either of those two
things are and I don't want you to tell
me because I won't understand but you're
telling me that those are two continents
that are important enough for language
to be getting all these prizes and
that's right in 2018 he received the
Apple price which is considered as a
kind of equivalent of Nobel Prize for
mathematics is given out by the king of
Norway I was actually asked to give a
public lecture about his work in Oslo
during the festivities one of the things
that I want to mention is that yes today
we talked about these two continents
number Theory and harmonic analysis and
how this link between them enables us to
translate seemingly inattractable
problems in number Theory to much more
feasible much more tractable uh you know
problems in harmonic analysis but in
fact that's not that's just the
beginning of the story because that was
the original setup the original a way
that how language thought about this
ideas at the outset right so the in the
80s these ideas of a language program
propagated to geometry and so
mathematicians were able to find the
similar patterns but in the study of of
uh things for complex numbers so we
talked about ellipticals for example
um in a more in the clock arithmetic the
solutions modular primes but you could
also look at Solutions in complex
numbers and in that case elliptical
appeared to us as a surface of a donut
as a as a Taurus
so
it turns out that the kind of things
that we observe in the language in the
original classical language program can
also be kind of
carried over to that domain where you
look at equations but now over complex
numbers
and it's very exciting and what is even
more exciting is that physicists also
observed similar patterns in the study
of what they call dualities of gauge
theories uh gauge theories are the is a
mathematical apparatus of uh of the
standard model of the best theories of
interaction of of subatomic particles
that we have although in this case we
are considering what's called
supersymmetric versions of those
theories which do not necessarily have
direct bearing on our universe but maybe
have bearing on some other universes who
knows in any case they are beautiful
mathematical gadgets and in those
mathematical gadgets we can observe
similar correspondences like the one
which we have discussed in other words
this is just the beginning of a story
there are many other things many other
places in mathematics and quantum
physics where similar patterns arise
so perhaps in another video we can
discuss discuss this but perhaps that's
that's plentiful for today well you made
it this far there's a good chance you'd
like to see even more from Edward
Frenkel I'm going to link to a playlist
of videos he's made here on number file
and a podcast he did with us as well as
a link to his book love and math which
is definitely worth checking out all
those links everything you need will be
in the video description